>> Tucker: OVER ON MSNBC
BRIAN WILLIAMS AND MARA GAY
GOT OUT THE ABICUS AND DID THE
MATH ON BLOOMBERG CAMPAIGN.
HERE IS HOW IT WENT.
>> WHEN I READ IT TONIGHT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA IT ALL BECAME
CLEAR.
BLOOMBERG SPENT $500 MILLION
ON ADS.
U.S. POPULATION 327 MILLION.
DON’T TELL US IF YOU ARE AHEAD
OF US ON THE MATH.
HE COULD HAVE GIVEN EACH
AMERICAN $1 MILLION AND HAD
LUNCH MONEY LEFT OVER.
INCREDIBLE WAY TO PUT IT.
>> IT’S AN INCREDIBLE WAY TO
PUT.
IT’S TRUE AND DISTURBING.
>> Tucker: BEFORE WE GET TOO
SELF-RIGHTEOUS, A LOT OF US
WENT TO JOURNALISM IN THE
FIRST PLACE BECAUSE WE WERE
BAD AT MATH.
SO WE WON’T SOLVE YOUR BUDGET
CRISIS ON THIS OR ANY OTHER
SHOW.
BUT EVEN SO, WE HAVE PRODUCERS
AND THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
GOOD AT MATH.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM?